so the issue here the privacy issue was
that initially when you signed up it the
app apparently got a lot of your Google
or gmail account information they've
released an update which they say fixes
that but Sony given your experience in
gaming and VR how serious do you think
this privacy issue really is I think
it's pretty serious when it includes
children Pokemon is making mobile gaming
accessible for very young children that
you're seeing out in the street that
aren't necessarily engaging with their
parents for permission this brings into
question Coppa compliance the Children's
Online Privacy Protection Act concerns
and I think that whether it was a
mistake or not or not on behalf of
Niantic this is something that needs to
be remedied pretty pretty quickly what
about some of the overall privacy I mean
overall security and safety issues and
maybe even legal issues yeah no I think
it calls into question some legal
questions around trespassing possession
do you own the augmented reality Pokemon
that's on your own physical property
that people are clambering over fences
to be able to get access to capturing
certain Pokemon does that raise
questions around indemnification you
know of Nintendo and Niantic against
prosecution questions like that come up
in this as well now Jitendra you are
very deep into the space gaming virtual
reality augmented reality you own a lot
of the equipment you play a lot of games
you know how serious do you think these
issues isn't it fascinating that we
talking about these implications a week
after the game is launched so that's how
successful the adoption rate has been
you know that if you look at the stock
movement in general what it's suggesting
is the expectation of how Nintendo can
monetize its other IPS that are not on
mobile because you know Nintendo will
probably make a fraction of what neon
tech ments from Pokemon go but this
whole new location it's probably not new
but location-based gaming will kind of
get a lot more impetus and an open new
avenues of monetization right like you
have location-based services
location-based advertising the
accessories and in Tendo is planning and
henceforth so the expectation that
Nintendo can get their mojo back of
reinventing the gaming space like they
did with the V has gone up now Sonny
you mentioned augmented reality but as I
understand it you don't actually think
this is in it really an AR game
absolutely not yeah I think it's much
more as Jitendra mentioned it's much
more of a location-based game my
definition of what augmented reality is
being an investor in the space is
computer vision application you're
seeing pokemon flying you know in the
middle of space for example there is no
dynamic real-time mapping of the
environment around you I think what it's
doing is it's actually drawing upon
Google Maps fixed latitude and longitude
data to be able to place you know gyms
and places to capture certain Pokemon
accordingly the only dynamic mapping
that seems to take place is what Niantic
is pushing so for example as you might
go to a particular location there might
be a new Pokemon that appears there
that's not necessarily representative of
any kind of real-time environmental
mapping though do you think it's not
well the type of game is not but but if
you look at all the location-based games
that you will see and you have seen in
the past but they didn't quite succeed
as much they didn't have Pokemon behind
them but that needs you to have mobile
devices with you you know so augmented
reality glasses the future that
Zuckerberg is pitching is that it's
going to be a mobile device you know way
down the line and and these experience
will naturally extend themselves to only
our platforms but they're not natively
AR games per se but like what a Nintendo
neon tech loves to call it as real-world
gaming so that genre oh here is
location-based